Sept en enclos.
Il y a un problème, qu'est-ce
qu'on fait?
Est-ce qu'on choisit de
préserver du territoire pour les
caribous, est-ce qu'on choisit
de développer encore un peu
plus?
PHILIPPE COUILLARD, ancien
premier ministre du Québec
- Oui, oui la sauvegarde
du caribou forestier, c'est
important, mais il est pas
question de sacrifier des jobs
en forêts ou en usine pour ça.
(applaudissements)
- Le dossier du caribou fait
des vagues depuis des années
au Québec. Les fonctionnaires,
les scientifiques et les experts
s'entendent : la population
de l'espèce est en déclin
en raison des activités
humaines notamment. Et Ottawa
monte maintenant le ton.
STEVEN GUILBEAULT min., Enviro.
et Changement climatique
est fait présentement
n'est pas suffisant
pour protéger l'espèce.
Le gouvernement du Québec
refuse de coopérer.
- Le gouvernement fédéral
donne donc à Québec jusqu'au20 r
de l'information concernant
la protection du caribou.
Si la réponse n'est pas
suffisante pour Steven
Guilbeault, Ottawa pourrait
user d'un décret encore
jamais utilisé dans
l'histoire canadienne,
ce qui lui permettrait
de protéger certaines portions
de l'habitat du caribou boréal.
L'ultimatum n'a pas tardé
à faire réagir à Québec
où on prépare une réponse.
PIERRE DUFOUR, ministre des
Forêts, de la Faune et des Parcs
- Il y en a des actions qu'on
fait. Mais à un moment donné,
il faut voir qu'est-ce... si
c'est en lien avec le milieu,
qu'est-ce qu'on est en mesure
de faire pour protéger, aussi,
ie de nos milieux.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québec
- Ça c'est un champ de
compétence du Québec. Donc,
on a une commissioante
qui se penche là-dessus.
- Les représentants de
l'industrie forestière,
qui pourraient perdre certains
territoires de coupe si Ottawa
va de l'avant, se font discrets
sur le débat. Au Conseil
de l'industrie forestière du
Québec, on espère la mise en
place de impliquant
tous les acteurs de la société
et tenant compte de tous
les facteurs qui ont ou peuvent
avoir un impact sur le caribou
et son habitat. Pour certaines
nations autochtones qui
multiplient les initiatives
pour protéger l'espèce,
c'est une toute autre réaction.
MARIE-HÉLÈNE ROUSSEAU, ingén.,
forest., Conseil innus Pessamit
- C'est une intervention
qui est plus que bienvenue.ienv.
Le caribou forestier
a toujours été présent
dans la culture innue.
- Certains estiment même que
si la menace du gouvernement
fédéral à exécution,
qu'elle pourrait changer
la façon dont le Québec
gère ses forêts.
ALAIN BRANCHAUD, DG, Société
nature, parcs du Ca, Québec
n choix à faire. On a
un sérieux enjeu de gouvernance
environnementale au Québec avec
un ministère, un ministre, qui
est à la fois responsable de
protéger le caribou forestier
et à la fois responsable de
promouvoir l'industrie
forestière.
- Les consultations publiques
du Québec sur le caribou
viennent d'ailleurs tout
juste de commencer. Celles-ci
se poursgré
l'ultimatum d'Ottawa.
Ici Colin Côté-Paulette, Radioé